Dr. Zakir, is it allowed for one to eat
and drink even when
the mu'adhin announces the uh call to
prayer for Fajr?
Is it allowed to eat and drink? Some
people, I'm not sure of whether it's
correct or not, but some people believe
that you can eat and drink all the way
up to the Fajr adhan and beyond. I'm
aware that there are some Muslims who
believe that you can eat and drink until
the Fajr adhan ends.
And there are some people who, when they
can hear various adhan of different
mosques from their house,
they wait till they hear the end of the
last adhan. So, if they can hear five,
six adhan, they wait till the last adhan
ends. Till that time they eat and drink.
In fact, this is not proved from any of
the hadith of the prophet.
And anyone who innovates a new thing
in the deen,
it has to be rejected.
It's mentioned in the hadith of Sahih
Bukhari, volume number three, hadith
number 2697, that anyone who innovates a
new thing in the deen, it has to be
rejected.
In fact, it's clearly mentioned in the
Quran in Surah Baqarah, chapter number
two, verse number 187, that eat and
drink until
the white thread of dawn
becomes distinct to you from the black
thread.
That means the moment dawn breaks,
moment you hear the adhan, you have to
stop eating.